[Music]
he said I love my wife I have no
interest in in seeing anybody else he
said but I keep having dreams about this
girl that I dated when I was in college
I can't make the dreams quit I asked him
I said did you sleep with her did you
commit fornication with her and he said
yeah I was like there's a tie that's
been made
so Satan knows I've got a right to
torment you and if I can't get you any
other way I'm going to send dreams those
ties have to be broken by faith in the
blood of Jesus and what he did on the
cross
yeah
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us again at LED live and we
cannot thank you guys enough because
without supporters like you this show
couldn't exist don't forget to like and
share this with everybody because all
that helps this video get into the
algorithm and we know that people are
going to be blessed by this episode
because this is a topic that a lot of
people struggle with man pornography is
just infiltrated our society when we
were growing up you had to like find a
magazine in a ditch or an abandoned
house or you had to really like be of
age and go into a store there's a lot of
like you know just shame and things that
came with that so now if a kid has a
phone they can be searching some
innocent like Spider-Man I actually
remember when they said don't let your
child search Spider-Man on Google
because they're going to see a
pornographic image and so we know that
the enemy is just out there attacking
full force I got my friend Eric Wilson
here if you guys don't know who he is
he's a wealth of knowledge we did a
documentary with him called the Dragon
revealed and it was so eye-opening and
awesome and since then we've just had a
really cool friendship we've had them on
the show many times so I'm excited to
get into this topic what do you got it's
good to be back again
um
well we're going to talk about
pornography but the only reason we're
talking about pornography is because
that's the contrast to moral Purity and
a lot of times people look at Purity as
if that's like well that's for you know
the straight laced people or that's you
know I don't want to be that kind of
person but they don't understand if
if you buy
if you buy something new
and it says it's new and you paid all
this money for it you don't want to get
home and find out it's got you know
somebody took and slopped pain all over
it and you want something that's pure
you want something that's clean you want
something that's brand new you don't
want something that's used and abused
yeah isn't that crazy how the devil has
turned Purity into something you don't
want like Ah that's too we should want
to be pure amen we should want to be new
when when Christ comes in us we become
new creatures we're his bride we want to
be a pure spotless bride who who Wants
to Marry a harlot we want to marry a
virgin right so yeah it's a good thing
but Satan has turned it into something
that's like I don't really want to be
here we're going to show how the enemy
is trying to destroy us but also what
Christ can do to completely restore us
new again amen the reason that I called
this message or this particular topic is
I called it Purity the bride and the
poison of serpents and a lot of people
don't realize that Satan and his evil
spirits are almost always symbolized in
scripture as serpents and a serpent has
venom well if they're speaking their
poison and it gets inside of our our
hearts and our heads our minds it can
influence the rest of our our life yeah
so that's what we want to look at is how
the enemy is using sensuality in all its
forms not just pornography even like we
talked about in anime and things like
that yes just slipping into cartoons and
things that children are being exposed
to well it's in all the advertising they
know that if you if you're advertising
themselves
um you know Armor All for your tires and
they'll put a woman there and a pair of
shorts all of a sudden they sell more
Armor All Satan is using that so right
here in second Corinthians 11 verse two
through three the Apostle Paul writes
and he tell tells us I am jealous over
you with a Godly jealousy for I have
espoused you that means I've engaged you
to one husband so that I may present you
as a chaste virgin to Christ the word
Chase that's where we get the word
Chastity
um it means clean innocent modest and
pure that's what God was telling he was
saying I want you to be clean and you
know I look back at when my wife and I
got married my wife was pure she had
never been with a man I was not I would
if I could go back and do anything I
would love to have went back amen and me
be perfectly clean my wife be perfectly
clean like she was because we would have
never known what it was like to have
kissed another person or exactly
anything that would have been wonderful
then the Apostle Paul goes on and he
says this right after he talks about I'm
engaging you as a pure virgin to Christ
he says but I fear lest by any means
just as the serpent beguiled Eve through
his subtlety so your mind should be
corrupted from the Simplicity that is in
Christ and in my mind I was like
corrupted yeah what is the serpent in
Simplicity in Christ have to do with him
giving us to Christ as a pure virgin
well then the Lord told me he said Eric
Look up the word Simplicity I was like
well I know what Simplicity means
and I lift it up in a strong concordance
in that verse what it means there the
word means singleness or Union
clear folded together as one
and those two become one two become one
so Paul says I don't want Satan to
corrupt your mind from the Simplicity
the union that you're supposed to have
with Christ like a husband and his wife
that's right the Bible says you know
don't be joined to a harlot because you
know you will become one flesh with that
heart that's right he wants you to
become one flesh with that spouse you're
going to spend your whole life with
that's right now Ephesians chapter 5 and
I love this one
he says husbands love your wives even as
Christ also loved the church and gave
himself for her do you know Mikey my
wife and I went through almost five
years divorced almost five years minus a
couple of months
I look back afterward after we came
through that battle after Christ rescued
me and brought my wife and I back
together brought me back to to God
and if anybody asked me what was the one
thing that caused your marriage to fall
apart caused you you know to do what you
did it was selfishness yeah that's the
one thing if I go into a marriage even
if somebody's dating if it's about me
when that person stops pleasing me then
I'm gonna go look for somebody else that
can please me it's true selfishness is
the cause and here he says we're to love
our wives as Christ loved us that means
when I was 18 years old or 25 years old
and I'm sitting on my computer in the
middle of the night looking at
pornography
Christ wasn't up there I'm killing him
no Christ loved me no and he worked and
and gave me repentance as a gift so the
next morning when I wake up and I feel
terribly guilty of what I've done
and I get on my knees Christ wasn't like
I'm not listening to him yeah Christ was
there amen and Christ was like Eric if I
was that patient with you can you not be
that patient with your spouse amen wow
so that things are worth waiting for yes
amen
so he says love our our wives even as
Christ loved the church
so that he might present her to himself
as a glorious Church a glorious
congregation not having spot or wrinkle
or any such thing but that we should be
holy and without blemish amen
so to love somebody and I was like well
how does loving somebody make them pure
man
if you're tolerant if you're patient if
you're kind if no matter what they say
to you and you love them it convicts
them it allows the spirit of God to work
in their heart that if you're being
agnostic or angry or antagonistic
towards somebody it shuts that door yeah
the Bible talks about don't return evil
with evil and I I've seen it if somebody
yells at you and you return by yelling
oh that's that's going to blow up but
somebody yells at you and you just keep
calm it
it brings down the wall or whatever amen
it uh disarms them or something well
it's like if it diffuses is the word
that amen yeah if my wife and I
start if one of us just starts
criticizing or being critical of the
other within a few minutes it's it's
like blood being spilled in a
a lake full of sharks
they come the evil spirits come rushing
in the moment they see you being
critical or being negative or or
unforgiving they rush in to make things
worse but like you said if we're kind if
we're patient if we're for forgiving
bearing the other person whatever they
the the the evil that they're doing to
us and you just take it patiently those
evil spirits don't have any ground they
they're trying and they can't get any
response yeah the Bible actually talks
about
um well it says don't return evil with
evil but with good and then it talks
about
being uh maybe you can help me with this
like having a character uh where
somebody's trying to come against you
they can't find any fault in you and
it's like keeping hot coals on that yeah
yes
amen
so in Ephesians 5 the Apostle Paul goes
on and he tells us so ought men to love
their wives even as their own bodies
amen for he that loveth his wife loveth
himself
for no man ever yet hated his own flesh
but nourishes it and cherishes it even
as the Lord does the church it's like
nobody wakes up in the morning and go
man I hate this arm and to get a hammer
and right I mean you don't do that
unless there's a demon that's
influencing exactly
um
you know if you get an injury you're
constantly trying to protect your own
flesh anything you're rubbing cream on
your face at night you want to stay
youthful and you're taking care of you
want to eat healthy so you don't get fat
and all these things so if I treat my
own flesh that way God is saying that's
how you should treat your wife she's
your flesh in your blood
and then he says for we are members of
Christ's body yea of his flesh and of
his bones
this is a great mystery but I'm speaking
concerning Christ and his church
so when all those things that Paul tells
us in in Ephesians 5 or that the Lord
tells us through Paul about a husband
and his wife it's really about us and
Christ yeah beautiful amen
this was one that you just quoted
Matthew 19. Jesus says for this cause
shall a man leave his father and mother
and shall cleave to his wife and they
twain shall become one flesh
a lot of times I've had people that have
called us or they've written to us and
they've said yeah but that just means
you know when you're in bed I'm like no
it doesn't mean we when you get married
and you consummate that marriage you're
one flesh for the rest of your life
right unless God severs that yeah if
you're the the husband and you go to
work and the woman she stays at home is
that your money that you earned oh it's
our money the Two Become One you might
be working
is making the ends meet and the other
one's raising the child that's like one
unit so this hand is writing the check
and this hand is holding the phone
talking to the the person that's asking
for the check right this is the wife and
this is the husband or reverse exactly
um it's funny because
when we become one flesh with our spouse
I can remember when I was younger
hearing stories of some of the the
veterans that were in Vietnam in the
Vietnam War and there were true stories
where a man would be in the field and he
would get a terrible wound in battle and
the moment that he got hit with that
attack his wife would be standing
washing dishes in America thousands of
miles away she'd be in the kitchen
washing dishes and she would feel the
pain in the exact place where he was hit
wow there is something Supernatural that
happens in a marriage when it's done
under God amen amen I don't know if
anybody's ever seen the film it was
called fireproof a powerful film on
marriage I recommend everybody watch it
when you look at what God wants for a
man and a woman as a husband and a wife
he wants both of them to have Purity he
wants there to be Integrity I want to be
a man of integrity I want my son to be a
man of integrity I want my son to be a
man of Valor
if there's sexual sin
there will never be Valor you can see it
in a person's eyes and it was neat
because when we watched this film
Kirk Cameron who played one of the lead
parts in it at the at the end of the
film you see him running to meet the
lady that played his wife's part in the
film and you see him hugging her but you
don't see her face and Kirk Cameron said
for he did that on purpose because he
said I will never kiss anyone other than
my wife I made a promise to my wife
years ago that I would be
honest and faithful and true to her and
so for that scene I asked if my wife
could actually be the one who would make
the scene possible and so she came to
the set she put on a wig that matched
the actress's hair in the movie and wore
the dress that she wore we shot the
whole scene with silhouette so you can't
tell when you're watching fireproof but
when I'm kissing my wife I'm actually
kissing my wife Chelsea not the actress
in the film and that story sort of blew
up he's like oh can you believe it and I
thought um that's husband 101. uh made
that made that promise at the altar man
that's a man of God wow I mean to say
look I'm not throwing myself away for
you know a few dollars yeah and you see
that in Hollywood a lot like people who
are married who are uh doing things with
other people and they shouldn't be doing
yes yes this is another verse that you
brought out but it says but know ye not
that he which is joined to a harlot is
also one body
for two saith he shall be one flesh and
when you look at this picture I mean
you've got a man there with his
girlfriend and his girlfriend's friend
and he's talking to his girlfriend but
he's holding the hand
of her friend yeah
what's interesting is this verse doesn't
say when you come into the church and
walk down the aisle and say the vows you
become one flesh it actually says that
when you join to a Harley you become one
flesh so that's right this act of sex
should not be done with anyone else that
is the marriage if you will you know we
just it's kind of so loosely done now
like a hug or a handshake or something
and we're joining ourselves at so many
people but
in reality we're supposed to see
somebody that we know we would spend
forever with and when that act is done
that's it you're one flesh forever amen
amen look at this picture of this
husband and a wife
what color dress does she have on yeah
white for Purity do you know my
grandmother told me that she said Eric
she said when I was a little girl she
said if you were not a virgin you were
not allowed to wear a white dress on
your wedding that means everybody that
showed up at the wedding knew
everybody wears white I mean almost 99.9
of people wear a white dress to their
wedding how many of them are not pure
most of them and now it's just like
tradition I guess yeah it's tradition
but when my grandmother was a little
girl she said you were not permitted you
were not allowed to wear a white dress
and you know it's funny because I can
remember when my wife and I were married
um you get there to the The Altar and
the pastor is you know having you say
your vows and she says her vows and then
the last thing that the pastor would say
to the husband is you may now kiss the
brain kiss the bride do you know what
went through my mind when he said that
like I've kissed her all the time yeah
I've been kissing her for two years what
do you mean I may now kiss the bride and
it hit me the act of a kiss is the First
Union do you know what what else the
pastor will say he'll say who is here to
give this woman's hand in marriage and
I'm thinking well I've been holding her
hand for two years I've kept sister for
two years and God is like
weren't you supposed to be saving that
for today and do you know what what
brought what the Lord brought back to my
memory I can remember when I was a boy I
mean I was probably like 12 years old
the first time I kissed a girl yeah I
mean and I know that seems crazy you
know to a lot of the this generation
they're eight right I was 12. I thought
I thought the world had exploded when I
kissed that little girl I mean like
literally I was like I came home and I
was just like what just happened I mean
it was like literally Sparks and
fireworks and dopamine yeah and you know
what God was saying what if you had
saved that until your wedding day you
would never be able to separate a man
and a woman that's true God designed
that dopamine and all the fireworks he
meant for that to be there to lock you
guys together to where you'd be like if
that's the only person I'd ever kissed
or your spouse had ever kissed you would
have no one to compare it that's right
you'd be like they hung the moon you
know what I mean that's what God wanted
for us amen the unique thing is is he
can restore that no matter how far
you've Fallen that's right um in the Old
Testament the Hebrew people the
Israelites they were traveling from
Egypt all through the Wilderness to get
to the promised land which was called
Canaan we know that Kanan was really
just a symbol of Heaven
but what's amazing is is right when they
were on the on the verge of crossing
over the river Jordan into the the
Promised Land
Satan said I know how I can get them
he hired a a prophet named Balaam
and
he got him he said I'm going to hire you
I'm going to pay you and who knows how
much it had to be a lot of money I'm
going to pay you to come up on this
mountain and speak a curse over all
these million and a half two million
Israelites so that they won't they won't
they'll be devastated they won't be able
to fight everything they're doing won't
work and they'll leave and won't come in
and take over my country and Balaam got
up there and every time he opened his
mouth to speak a curse a blessing would
come out and the King that had hired him
balik he got so angry he was like what's
wrong with you and Balaam said I'm a
prophet of God I have no control of what
comes out of my mouth when you ask me to
prophesy yeah and balak said okay forget
it don't say another word I'm not paying
you anything go home well Balaam
apparently goes home and that night he's
thinking about all that money that he
just lost instead of thinking about God
and the devil inspired him with a
thought he came back the next day to
balak and he said you know I know how
you can get the children of Israel I
don't even have to speak a curse overall
he said send a bunch of your young
unmarried women to hold a feast a party
right outside the camp of Israel and
they're going to be playing the kind of
music that the Israelites don't listen
to they're going to be dressing in
clothing that's a lot more immodest than
what the Israelites are used to he said
the Israelite the young Israelite men
will be intrigued and they'll fall into
sexual sin and God's blessing will be
removed from them wow so you know what
they did they did just that and all the
Israelite men they were sitting there
one you know evening and all of a sudden
they hear this music they're like oh
what is that music that's different we
need to go investigate that what is that
so they're sneaking and they get near
the the camp where there's fires and
there's all these beautiful young women
and they're they're not dressed modestly
and they're worshiping their pagan gods
and I can I can almost imagine one of
the guys going you know those are pagans
but we ought to go in and witness to
them we need to go witness to them so
they go in and start talking to the
girls to befriend them and before the
night's over with they're fornicating
with them
and because of the fornication they're
bowing down to the idols that the girls
worship which we see it happen with
Solomon too we had a thousand wives and
by the end of it he was
falling into all their Pages that's
exactly right that's exactly what Jesus
says do not be unequally yoked amen not
because he's
whatever and he's not like racist or
something like that he's just saying
it's really hard when you're together
and you have different beliefs I mean
even with just different denominations
it can be hard and
um yeah he just he wants you to be
equally yoked where you have the same
beliefs you serve the same God you can
raise your children believing the same
way imagine your children are being
raised and Mom says this is okay and dad
says this isn't that's right and he's
doing it for our benefit because he's
like he knows marriage can be hard
enough he doesn't he's trying to take
some of the the open doors that the
enemy normally uses he's trying to keep
those close so we don't have to deal
with that Samson fell for it too that's
right let me read just a little bit this
is from First Corinthians chapter 10 and
psalm 106. it says all of these things
that happened back there with Balaam and
balak and the children of Israel all
these things are our examples to the
intent that we should not lust after or
desire evil things as they also lusted
now look at this word neither let us
commit fornication as some of them
committed and fell in one day 23
000 men died that night
they went in there and they were joined
to those women in fornication and sexual
immorality and they died 23
000 men wow
he says and then this is what it says in
uh in Psalm it says for they joined
themselves unto Baal peor and they ate
the sacrifices of the dead and I read
that and I was like okay wait a minute
they went in here and they were joined
to these girls it doesn't say they had
you know sex with with Idols the women
worshiped the idols so when the men were
joined to the women the demons that
those women were worshiping now had free
access to the men that's true they
became one flesh with the women and you
know what that's like that's like if I'm
uh let's say that a woman meets some guy
you know maybe she's on a cruise or
she's out on the weekend she meets this
really really super nice guy and
um and she's like head over heels and
she says man I would never normally give
myself but I really like this guy and
she gives herself to him for that night
she goes home the next week and finds
out she's got a venereal disease
whatever he has when she joins herself
to him now becomes hers
what if he had AIDS now she's got AIDS
what if he had a demon of of who knows
murder or or
pornography or a demon of Witchcraft or
a demon of bitterness if it's in his
life if she becomes one with him those
demons now have access to torment and
influence her life yeah yeah we open up
doors for the enemy I heard a question
the other day
can Christians be possessed and it's
like
to me it's it's a it's a no-brainer yes
of course if you're a Christian and
you're doing things you shouldn't be
doing you're giving the enemy a foothold
you're opening the door yeah you're not
just like the day you accepted Christ
now it's like you can do whatever you
want and Satan can't come into you or
possess you and things like that even
the disciples yeah Judas was hand-picked
by Jesus and yet it says that Satan
entered into him it says that even to
Peter and it also talked about James and
John yeah he said you don't even know
what Spirit you're of right now so the
enemy whether it was literally inside
them or just whispering to them it still
had an influence yeah and that's scary
that is so you know we talked about that
being joined to bail peor so if if a
girl looks beautiful and she seems
really sweet and she's doing witchcraft
at home or ancestral magic at home yoga
and you are joined to her whatever
spiritual things she's involved in now
you know become yours because the Two
Become One flesh now listen to what
First Corinthians says chapter 10 verse
20. and this I say that the things which
the Gentiles the Heathen the unbelievers
sacrifice they are sacrificing to devils
and not to god wow people that worship
idols whether it be Buddhists or Hindus
or Taoist or native American Indians or
whatever
they know that that piece of stone does
not do anything they know that they put
a food and drink offering out there they
know that piece of stone doesn't eat
that yeah
that Idol is a symbol of a spiritual
power that they know empowers their life
that's right they know that it's just a
symbol but a lot of people especially
Christians in America they think oh
what's wrong with those dumb people why
are they worshiping that that stick or
that stone they're not worshiping that
that's only a symbol of what they're
worshiping right so the Apostle Paul
tells us they're sacrificing to devils
and not to God and I would not that you
should have fellowship with Devils the
word Fellowship there in the Greek means
Union or be a partaker of
Paul says I don't want you eating with
them I don't want you you know having
doesn't mean that you've got to act like
uh you're better than other people but
if they're serving the devil why would
you go have you know dinner with them
unless you're there to witness to them
right and if you witness to them and
they're not interested how can two walk
together except they be agreed you know
how can you sit down and say oh I'm just
hanging out with these people what do
you have in common with them right yeah
if they're Living For The Devil in in
the world what do you have in common
with them that happened in my life you
know I when I stopped drinking stop
smoking those friends still came over
and I didn't
I didn't condemn them or anything I was
just like uh when it would pass my way I
was just like oh no I'm good man you go
for it I never said like I don't do that
anymore or you can't do that in my house
or whatever
um those friends just stopped coming
around and I was like was that all our
friendship was based off of
and like you said you just don't have
things in common anymore and I didn't
even
make a big deal about it but I think the
spirit of conviction was there you know
yeah it's weird I'm glad you said that
because like when I quit drinking I was
worried like how am I going to get rid
of all my Heathen friends I didn't have
to yeah they didn't want to hang around
me anymore that's right yeah they're all
saying you know GD this and f word and I
quit cussing and it was like I didn't
want to hear it but they didn't want to
be around me because I wasn't acting
like that anymore that's interesting you
brought up custom because I didn't I
didn't take any special initiative to
stop cussing it just happened I did I
had to specifically stop I had to
surrender alcohol and weed to God
because it was a an addiction in my life
and cussing was just normal language I
mean it came out all the time I was a
rapper and I never really made a
initiative too but I was in church a lot
I had a lot of people doing Bible
studies at my home so I guess you know I
was kind of not cussing because of that
and then it just became normal and I
started noticing when people would cuss
in front of me they go oh sorry and I
was like that felt so foreign to me I
was like I've never had anybody
apologize for cussing in front of me and
then I I realized oh because they don't
hear me cussing amen I didn't even have
to say anything to them I never said
like oh you shouldn't say that I never
said that they would just cuss and say
oh sorry amen and it's just you know
that's beautiful yeah a lot of times
people will whether it be in a book like
a romance novel or even even in a
fantasy book
you can have an attachment to somebody
even though they're physically not there
I can remember when I was in high school
a lot of the boys would go to this place
in the mall called Spencer's you know
which sold all the kind of stuff that
your mama doesn't want you bringing home
and they'd buy big posters of you know
Sports Illustrated model right you know
and they hang them up on the back of
their bedroom door so that when they're
going to bed they'd shut the door and
lay there in their bed and just stare at
this girl that you know has less on that
are you know bra and panties
there can be a soul tie there can be a
connection made in the heart even there
with celebrities the same thing can
happen even as a child I can remember
watching a certain show it was called
Buck Rogers and there was a lady that
played in the show as a science fiction
movie her name was Aaron gray and I
thought she was beautiful and I remember
I used to love it's like I couldn't wait
to see that show not just because the
story of the show but because I liked
the way she looked yeah as a little boy
I mean I was probably 9 or 10 years old
so that can have an effect on people and
the same thing if somebody's worshiping
demons and I've got a crush on them and
my heart is joined to them
that what's in their life can have
access to me yeah there's even such
thing as uh emotional adultery you know
like if you're if you're a husband and a
wife
and you
just kind of gravitate towards somebody
at work or something of the opposite sex
and you
you just start falling for them
emotionally you don't have to do
anything and it's still your heart is
with them you know that's right yeah
well these are two people that two of
the actresses that have played in a lot
of the the new Marvel and DC Comics uh
Gal Gadot and also Amy Adams you know
she played the new Lois Lane and
Superman or Man of Steel and Gal Gadot
played Wonder Woman
you look at them and Gal Gadot sort of
she sort of portrays more of a risque
character like when you see her in in
her interviews and stuff when you look
at Amy Adams normally you think she's
more clean cut Girl Next Door yeah the
girl next door she's still you know
attractive but just more clean cut but
you have no idea what they're involved
in in their personal lives that's true
well I was doing research and I don't
recommend it but I was doing research
online to find out what other movies Gal
Gadot had played in well Gal Gadot had
played a lesbian in numerous other films
oh wow she played a lesbian where she
was mouth kissing other women and people
say yeah but she's not really homosexual
well that makes it even worse gay for
pay yeah I mean like if somebody really
feels like they're gay that's bad and
you pray for them but if somebody's
willing to do that just for a money
that's even worse well then I looked up
Amy Adams and I don't remember the name
of the show but there was a it was a
movie and there was actually two parts
to it you may remember it but she played
a lesbian part and she kissed women the
redhead yeah Amy Adams did uh I wish I
could remember the name of it but it's
probably irrelevant but anyway so if
somebody has a crush on these two women
and these two women are being influenced
by Demons of homosexuality or lesbianism
or whatever
those things can begin influencing you
yeah they call these people influencers
they literally label them influencers
because of how much influence they have
over society and people like Madonna and
Lady Gaga and all these people they will
openly admit that we are trying to push
this homosexual agenda we want to make
it so mainstream that it seems normal
and that's what happened here like they
were paid to do it because that film
company wanted had an agenda they want
to normalize this that's right it's not
just the ladies these are two of the men
that have also played in a lot of the
the very popular films in the last five
years Henry Cavill and Chris Pine you
know who played Captain Kirk and he also
played in the Wonder Woman all right
um You don't know what what's in these
men's lives so if girls look at these
men and they're like hey these guys are
really you know they're hunks or they're
tough or they're gorgeous or whatever
you don't know what that guy was raised
you don't know if if he might be having
sex with am animals or you have no idea
what's in his life yeah so if you're
lusting after him in your heart
and a lot of times people will say yeah
but you can't you can't change your
heart well you're right you can't that's
right only Christ can and he can and he
will if you'll surrender it to him King
of Hearts amen
and this is what
this is what hit me and you touched on
this listen to what Jesus said in
Matthew 5.
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ says to
each of us
you have heard that it was said by them
of old time that thou shalt not commit
adultery
but I say unto you that whosoever
looketh on a woman to lust after her
with desire for her has already
committed adultery with her in his heart
so people say what I didn't do anything
I didn't touch her I didn't you know
there was no physical intimate it
doesn't have to be that's right if your
heart has done it it's as good as done
yeah can you imagine just finding out
that your wife has a crush at work that
she's never touched it's heartbreaking
it is even if that would be yeah I've
never done anything that would be
devastating Proverbs is full of stuff
about adultery and fornication I wish I
had read this when I was young when I
was 10 years old I wish somebody had sat
down and said Eric look at me let me
tell you this is how this works it says
for the lips of a strange woman that
means somebody who's not your wife the
lips of a strange woman drop as a
honeycomb her mouth is smoother than oil
it means her words her flattery
but her end is bitter as wormwood and as
sharp as a two-edged sword her feet go
down to death and her steps take hold on
hell
lust not after her beauty in thine heart
neither let her take thee with her
eyelids do you know in the advertising
industry the eyes are the number one way
they get you they use the eyes because
if they can use the eyes the eyes catch
you the eyes are like the window to the
soul it's true there's a lot of emotion
in the eyes you can tell if somebody's
happy or sad or yes
seductive even yeah if you look just at
magazine covers just go online look up
magazine covers and look at the eyes
look at how many of the covers they show
a picture of eyes
neither let her take thee with thine
eyes and this is what hit me
for by means of a [__] woman a man is
brought to a piece of bread I cannot
tell you how many men Christian men that
go to church have contacted our ministry
and they've said I don't know what's
wrong it's like I can't get ahead I'm
working I start working more and it's
like there's a hole in the bottom of my
wallet and no matter how much I put in
there it's always gone and I don't know
what it is and oftentimes the Lord will
will inspire me or impress me to ask
them has there been any moral impurity
in your life is there any pornography
and if I ask that they always they get
really quiet and they'll say yeah
there's been pornography and I say God
says if you by whoredom
you'll be brought to a piece of bread
you know it's interesting I I don't know
where he got this in the Bible maybe
you've heard it but I remember when um
I was starting to do Bible studies me
and my wife were we're living together
not married and we were we were learning
we were studying the Bible and it was
the Bible that convicted us about
everything about drug use living
together all that
and I remember hearing about you know
that we shouldn't live together and I
said well what exactly
what is wrong with it or what will it
cause if we are and he said I don't know
where he got this he said that uh
actually it'll cause you to financially
like decrease you know and stuff like
that I don't know where he got that from
but I wonder if it has something to do
with that it may have it's like a curse
of finances and things yeah
but it and it's not that God wants to
reverse that but he's like
it's not that God is bringing this curse
upon you it's like when his protection
is removed Satan is the one that's
destroying you right in First
Corinthians 6 18 and also Proverbs 6 32
listen to what it says my son my
daughter flee from fornication
for every sin that a man doeth without
the body or I'm sorry every sin that a
man doeth is without the body
but he that committeth fornication is
sinning against his own body in all of
these verses in the New Testament when
you look up the word fornication that's
the Greek word pornia so all the way
back there two thousand years ago God
already said that's what it is that's
where we get the word pornography
poornia is the Greek word which means
fornication that's right
um if somebody's married fornication is
I'm just going to do this for a night
this is not I'm not leaving my wife to
marry another I'm just going to fool
around on the side that's fornication if
you're not married anything you do
physically is fornication
so yeah
to to commit adultery is like I have I
have left I have abandoned
then it says for whosoever committeth
adultery with a woman or a man lacketh
understanding
he that doeth it destroyeth his own soul
and I'm going to tell you I was addicted
to porn for years I mean even though I
went to church it was like it was a
struggle yeah and when god Set Me Free
from it you you cannot believe what
happened like my mind it felt like all
of a sudden God put all the pieces back
where they were supposed to be and you
could think clearly I could read the
Bible there was Joy again God blessed
the work of my hands whereas before the
work of my hands was like I couldn't get
ahead we've done shows where there's
scientific research of what porn
actually does to your brain it literally
does something to your brain and it it
uh yes it out of whack man I've seen
I've seen photographs where they've
taken images of the brain and they've
shown this is somebody on crack cocaine
here's somebody on pornography and the
brain looks almost identical the damage
wow it's scary I like this picture this
was supposed to be a representation of
Eve in the Garden of Eden if you look at
her on the left that's her when she
first meets you know Adam when she opens
her eyes you know and God's like this is
your husband Adam and you look at her
she's beautiful and she's she's got joy
and there's like a sparkle in her eye
and then she gets tempted by the serpent
by the devil and you look at her on the
right there's shame there's guilt
there's confusion there's doubt there's
fear all of that comes from sin
that that's very interesting I want to
be a
pretty transparent here um years ago I
worked at a place on the mall called Hot
Topic and I remember me and my boss
we would we would see women all the time
come in the mall
and we would see some of them they were
like beautiful but they
just had a certain look to him that was
like yeah she's she's not a kind person
or whatever
but we would notice like we would look
more younger girls and we're like why we
didn't want to be like that we didn't
want to be like looking at younger girls
that were not our age range and then he
said oh it's because they've been they
haven't been used up by the world in
abused like they still have a joy to
them they're coming in all happy like
look at this I'm playing and the other
one
where is there so and so you know it's
like yeah I know I know exactly what you
mean it's just been used and abused by
the world and it and it destroys the the
character like this other picture of you
here yeah it is so imagine if we did
remain pure until marriage and into
adulthood and things like that you you
would always look like this picture on
the left if you have ever sinned
wake up in the morning and look at
yourself in the mirror when you're
brushing your teeth you see it in your
eyes wow if you've sinned and you feel
remorse what you see it
but if you haven't if you've lived for
the Lord you get up in the morning you
brush the teeth and it's like you don't
even notice it's like there's joy and
there's peace amen God God's word says
in Proverbs it says great peace have
they that love my law I think it's in
Proverbs or Isaiah
so now we're going to talk a little bit
about the ties the soul ties uh it says
that when a man and his wife are married
they become one flesh but it says don't
you realize that when a man becomes one
with a harlot they also become one flesh
so we've seen that Jesus talks about
adultery can be committed in the heart
it can be visually on a computer screen
or on a an iPhone screen or an Android
screen or on a movie screen or TV
whatever girl walking by that's right
there are there are connections that are
made called soul ties and you're not
going to find the term soul ties in the
Bible but the the
the principle of how it works is clearly
established in the Bible when when
second or first Corinthians chapter 6
says that you become one flesh that is a
tie right it means your heart the word
Soul it means your heart is tied to that
person this picture I put up because
you're seeing what it looks like when
there's a soul tie I have talked to
people that they know it's not going to
work their parents don't want it
together they know they're they look at
it it's never going to work but they
can't let go yeah and that's what you're
seeing here you're seeing a man and a
woman and it's like they both know this
can't work but they can't let go I mean
even with them on opposite sides of the
wall their hands are still joined that's
because of the chemical and spiritual
connection that's been made inside and
God created four one couple that's right
now a lot of people will talk about
chemistry which you know all I had great
chemistry I met this woman you know and
and sometimes you can be like you said
you can be walking through the mall or
through a store like Target or wherever
and you see somebody and you walk by
them and you're like why was I attracted
to that person right
oftentimes
the enemy is influencing you but the
enemy can also be working through them
to influence you if they have a door
open to a spirit of sensuality or a
immorality or seduction if that spirit
is in their life it will influence it
will try to influence everybody that
they come in contact with God wants us
to be modest you know he wants us to be
drawn to the uh the attraction of the
personality that's right of the
character yeah that's right this is an
advertisement for a perfume company and
it's funny because they named the
perfume modern Muse well amuse is a
demon it's an evil spirit back in the
Greeks and Romans they knew they talked
about them they talked about the Muse
was the one that inspired actors to act
so here you've got you know an
attractive lady she's got this new
perfume on and it's called modern Muse
and it says be an inspiration yeah be an
inspiration
which is it comes from the root word and
spirited right and spirited a spirit is
gone into you what's interesting is is
that we're talking about chemistry
perfume companies don't just simply
throw some stuff in a bottle and shake
it up and go that one's good we'll keep
it that one's not good we'll throw it
out
they know the chemicals that are
released with within the human brain and
within the body especially something
called pheromones yeah pheromones are a
a scent that is put off by the body to
let your marriage partner know that you
are attracted that you are aroused that
you are it's something that God
he meant for a husband and a wife to to
come together and for there to be
certain things there that would trigger
one another that hey this would be a
great time for us to you know be
intimate
these companies that perfume and the
cologne companies
they have found how to mimic those
identically so they can put certain
chemicals into those colognes and and
perfumes that trigger feelings of
sensuality feelings of lust or feelings
of beauty or feelings of Attraction and
that's terrifying I can remember when I
was a young boy we had like a youth
group called Pathfinders and we had a
lady that was the leader of it she was a
great lady super nice lady but there
wasn't anything physically
that would catch my attention I mean I
was you know 12 13 14 years old there
was nothing about her that was even the
least been intriguing that way and I'll
never forget she came in
to teach the the youth group one night
and all of a sudden it was like there
was just an attraction and I was like
and I was in my mind at 12 13 14 years
old I was thinking I've never even
considered thoughts of her why and then
I noticed by the end of the night she
smells different and didn't realize till
years later why it was I don't think she
knew what she was doing she probably
just smelled it was like oh that smells
good you know but the people that put it
together they knew what they were doing
yeah look at this one this is a perfume
it's called hypnotic poison oh wow isn't
that scary yeah Deuteronomy chapter 32
says for their Vine is the vine of Sodom
and of the fields of Gomorrah yea their
grapes are The Grapes of gall or poison
and their clusters are bitter their wine
is the poison of dragons and the cruel
Venom of asps wow I've never heard that
that's scary yeah that's like you know
and this can be a man or a woman so if
you're a young lady and you're listening
to this or an older lady and you're
listening to this remember the same
thing applies for a man that does for a
woman
when that person talks to you and is
complimenting you or or praising you
remember it's the poison of dragons if
you are engaged if you are a spouse you
know if you've got if you're married
somebody else shouldn't be doing that
that's right you've got you've got to
say God I need you to give me
discernment so I know how to talk to
somebody and keep it where it needs to
be that's right
in Revelation Chapter 14 verse 8.
and we're living in this time yeah
listen to what it says
they're following another Angel another
messenger saying Babylon has fallen is
Fallen that great City because she made
all nations drink of the wine of the
wrath of her fornication
in the Bible there's two kingdoms the
Kingdom of Light and the kingdom of
darkness there's the prince of Light
which is Christ Jesus and the prince of
darkness which is Satan
but you also have if you have a kingdom
you have to have a a capital of that
Kingdom right the capital of the Kingdom
of Light is Jerusalem the captain of the
kingdom of darkness is Babylon
Babylon is not simply Rome or someplace
in in Iraq Babylon is everything that is
not part of God's City the New Jerusalem
so here it says that great city has
fallen because she has made all the
nations drink of the wine of the wrath
of her fornication I looked up that word
wrath in the Greek in the Strong's
Concordance listen to what the
definition is to breathe hard The
Passion of oh wow the Wrath I mean have
you ever seen an animal in heat it's
like they're panting yeah if you've ever
seen which I pray you haven't somebody
in that kind of a situation with a woman
or a man
there's heavy breathing yeah panting wow
so it talks about Babylon they're drunk
with seduction from this wine which is
false doctrines and things right but not
just that
oh yeah I'm sure let me show you what
else Revelation says about Babylon it
says she has become the habitation of
devils remember we talked about if
you're joined or Harlot whatever demon
she's got now have access to influence
your life maybe they don't come into you
but they you brought them into your home
that's right if I go if I go buy an AC
DC album because I used to listen to
that you know when I was younger if I
bring that album into my house the
demons that are with that album that are
with those singers they have free legal
right to come into my house it's like
bringing a witchcraft book or something
yeah same thing yes exactly right in the
Bible they
they piled hundreds of dollars or
thousands of dollars worth of Witchcraft
books in a fire to get rid of that stuff
amen and we're going and bringing it in
amen and we're acting like what can't
affect us because I'm a Christian yeah
so it says this world system has become
the habitation of devils and the
stronghold of every foul spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird
isn't it funny because the Holy Spirit
the spirit of God is symbolized as a
dove a Pure White Dove but yet Babylon
has become the cage and the hold of
every unclean and hateful birth of a
vulture or something yeah nasty yeah
those old crows
and then it goes on in Revelation 18 and
says alas alas that great city that was
clothed in fine linen and purple and
Scarlet and was decked with gold and
precious stones and Pearls for in one
hour so great riches has come to naught
now listen to this
for by thy Merchants for thy Merchants
were the Great Men of the earth and by
thy sorceries were all nations to see
and I was like so what does that have to
do with fornication let me show you
something interesting sorceries
the Bible says in Hosea chapter 4 and
Jeremiah 3
thus saith the Lord the spirit of
whoredoms has caused you to err
and they have not known the Lord known
Adam knew his wife Eve and they became
one flesh if we know the Lord Jesus
Christ we become one flesh or one spirit
with him
know ye not that he which is joined to a
hurl it is one body
for two saith he shall be one flesh but
he that is joined unto the Lord Jesus
Christ is one Spirit if you yield
yourself to Christ the spirit that was
in Christ now has free access to come
into you amen amen
that word sorcery in the Greek this is
the definition pharmacia pharmacia and a
lot of people can get really worked up
about that and say Pharmaceuticals and
stuff yes it does include that but I'm
not going there yeah look at what the
other definitions are medication magic
spell giving witchcraft potion a
druggist a poisoner and a magician
by thy sorceries where all nations
deceived and it says her fornications in
the verse prior to that yeah
so is there a connection between
fornication and sorcery I'm noticing
that word poisoner and those scriptures
are saying that a harlot is like poison
yes yes
and we know that Babylon is referred to
as a harlot so what I found was and this
shocked me years ago when my wife and I
when the Lord had first brought us back
together her best friend worked for the
for the state doing abstinence programs
for public schools teaching young people
how to to stay clean to not you know
give themselves over to immoral it was
very awesome Rings yeah yeah
um but she shared something with us that
I'll never forget
she said Eric she said
when a mother is nursing breastfeeding
her or infant her baby she said there is
a chemical that is released inside the
baby's brain called oxytocin
dopamine is also released dopamine is
the precursor oxytocin is like the most
addictive chemical that we've been able
to find oh wow uh but what's amazing is
is that baby that's why a baby it says
can a mother forsake her nursing child
that's why because not only is that
chemical released in the baby's brain
but it's released in the mother's brain
while she's nursing so when the baby and
the mother are there and that that Union
God designed these chemicals to be
released that were addictive so that the
child would never forsake the mother and
the mother would never forsake the child
amen well this friend of ours told us
something she said do you know the other
time that oxytocin is released inside
the human brain
and I was like I have no idea she said
when a husband and wife are having
intercourse during the the climax of the
event
that chemical by God was designed to be
released inside the husband's brain and
his wife's brain to addict them to one
another to make them to where you
couldn't separate them they would never
leave each other
and then she said Eric she said we have
found that the same thing happens with
pornography or if you're sleeping with
somebody and you're not married don't
yeah
yeah it's addictive Satan said I'll get
them addicted to drugs I'm just going to
use the drugs that God put inside of
their own brains and bodies yeah he
wants to pervert everything that God
made God made it for a reason Satan says
I'm going to make you get it this way
that's right
so four four of the the main chemicals
that we looked at there are basic
endorphins which you get like a runner's
high if you go out jogging you know and
after a little while it's like something
just kicks in and you're like you feel
like you're floating that's endorphins
uh the pheromones we talked about those
are the chemicals that your body
releases to let your spouse know that
you're aroused you're interested you're
excited
the dopamine which yeah there's stuff
all over the Internet about dopamine now
I mean dopamine they're using that in
movies to to get you addicted they have
found certain colors and certain sounds
and everything to to trigger the release
of dopamine every addiction is dopamine
like yeah every addiction so cigarettes
crack whatever it is it's releasing
dopamine and so a lot of times when
people are like oh I'm I've been clean I
don't do crack anymore but I drink
coffee like crazy or whatever you know
it's like they find something else to
replace it yeah but it's still dopamine
so that's what the enemy is doing and
what's weird is is
let's say that let's say that a young
woman she meets a guy maybe they're
together for a couple of weeks and and
she just falls in love with him and
she's like you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
sleep with him tonight so she sleeps
with him but she doesn't realize he's
already slept with 10 girls or let's say
five girls before her
Okay so
those five girls that he slept with
before her what demons did they have in
their life so those demons have
influence on him
well what about those five girls how
many people have they slept with well
they've slept with five people a piece
that's 25 other people that have evil
spirits that have influence here that
have influence here that now have
influence into this girl's life Wow
Satan is using this to connect people
I've had people that have called our
ministry I've had a man one time that
called and he said I'm a Christian I go
to church every week I've been married
to my wife for you know 20 some years he
said I love my wife I have no interest
in seeing anybody else he said but I
keep having dreams about this girl that
I dated when I was in college I can't
make the dreams quit I've prayed and
they won't quit and I asked him I said
did you sleep with her did you commit
fornication with her and he said yeah I
was like there's a tie that's been made
so Satan knows I've got a right to
torment you and if I can't get you any
other way I'm going to send dreams wow
those ties have to be broken by faith in
the blood of Jesus and what he did on
the cross amen I want to show you a CBS
article from CBS News it was titled
pornography and suicide
let me show you something
this is the article this was in 2019 it
says adult film performers say that the
state of mental health in the industry
needs more attention wow mental health
in the pornography industry the lady
that wrote this she was interviewing
a lady named Lynn Lynn says while online
platforms have Diversified revenue
streams and allowed online payments to
be paid directly to performers Lynn said
that the internet has also brought
unintended consequences to those bearing
at all back in the day before the
internet if you had a fan who didn't
like you they couldn't access you in
real time and start tearing you down I
mean you know like you said you find a
magazine and laying in the gutter or you
have to go to a a a naughty store and
buy it and there's all this shame and
guilt and and what if they got a camera
and somebody's seen me
you couldn't have any access to the the
porn stars
or belittling you and making fun of you
Lynn said but with the internet now they
can Lynn said she has deep concerns for
today's porn performers when I was young
I never really felt I was in a position
where if something happened to me I
wouldn't have somebody I could turn to
that would be able to see me through
that dark period however the actors of
today we lose a lot of them because
there's a lot of suicide for many
different reasons this lady does not
identify the spiritual aspect but she's
saying we're seeing a lot of porn stars
committing suicide between late 2017 and
early 2018
five porn actresses died by suicide in
12 weeks that's that's sad yeah I mean
that's sad she said I've dealt with
depression and anxiety for many years
but I didn't think it was something I
needed to advocate for my community
until we had that bump in suicides a lot
of people don't realize that most of the
female porn stars most of them a large
percentage of them
were either raped or molested and that's
why they're in the porn industry yeah
not all but a large percentage of them
are well if you've been raped or
molested there's demons that have come
into your life influencing tormenting
causing depression causing Suicidal
Thoughts a lot of the women that are in
the porn industry have also had
abortions either in or out of the time
they were in the industry when someone
has an abortion there's access to evil
spirits because of that bitterness
self-hatred you know depression all
kinds of stuff yeah she goes on and says
nothing like this ever happens in a
vacuum and anyone choosing to take their
own life it's probably a Confluence of
factors and they've been fighting for a
long time
rise says that in many ways the adult
entertainment industry is more
accessible source of work for for people
who have are managing underlying
physical or mental illnesses
because you can set your own time you
can set your own schedule she goes on
and says the truth is I do find that
there are a lot of people in the sex
industry who are living on the margins
in some way and that includes mental
illness wow so I'm looking at this woman
who's all painted up in makeup and I
have no idea if she was molested or
raped or what she's dealing with and if
you become one with her by lusting over
her all of a sudden you can start having
evil spirits influencing your life and
attacking you definitely now let's get
to the good part how does Jesus set us
free amen Jeremiah chapter 2 and chapter
3 I really encourage people to to read
those two chapters
thus saith the Lord I remember Thee the
kindness of thy Youth and the love of
thine espousals when thou chased after
me in the wilderness yea in a land that
was not sown
Israel that's speaking of you and I
Israel was Holiness unto the Lord and
you were the first fruits of his
increase Jesus is saying I remember when
I took you by the hand as my bride in
the middle of the night like I was
eloping with you I remember when you
followed me and I was taking you into a
desert and you know it's funny because
you can see like young couples when they
first come together and the dad's like
you know honey listen I don't think this
guy's the right guy for you and she's
like why he's like oh he's not got a job
he's not got an education he's not she's
like Dad he'll the girl's like he'll be
you know number one I know he can do
this
that's what Jesus was saying he's like I
remember when you chased after me when I
was taking you to a Wilderness wow what
have I done that you forsook me now why
are you going to talk about Hosea so I
just think about you know that is a I'm
assuming it's a real story but it was
yes God gave it to be in the scriptures
to show us his love for us marry this
Harlot he marries the Harlot she keeps
going astray and going back to her old
tricks and stuff and he keeps going back
forward and that's the way God is after
us amen we fell in love with him we
received him but at some point we get
seduced by the world and we go astray
he's still pursuing us he still wants us
he's not looking at us like you dirty
Harlot I mean
we are but he still wants us he wants to
clean us up he wants to bring us back
into the um the marriage relationship
with him yeah if anybody has ever
struggled with uh if you're having a
struggle in your marriage read the book
of Hosea because that is that's an
actual literal account that really
happened it wasn't a parable amen God
goes on and says thus saith the Lord
what iniquity or perversity have your
fathers found in me that they are gone
far from me and have chased after Vanity
Vanity means after something that's not
going to come to any good it's just a
waste of time yeah they say if a man put
away his wife and she'd go from him and
become another man's Shahi return unto
her again shall not that lamb be greatly
polluted it actually says that in the
Old Testament in the first five books
then the Lord says but thou has played
the Harlot with many lovers
yet return unto me saith the Lord for I
am married unto you amen only
acknowledge thine iniquity that thou
Hast transgressed against the Lord thy
God that's our God Amen he's like you
haven't cheated on with one you've
played the Harlot with many but yet
returned to me because I'm married unto
you wow
thus saith the Lord
turn o backsliding children and I will
heal your backslotting that's
I mean what more can you ask for yeah he
gives us the victory
Jesus said all power is given unto me in
heaven and on Earth he said that when he
when he went back to heaven to receive
his crown and His glory and he came back
to the Earth
he says I give unto you power and
authority over all devils and to cure
all diseases
and he sent them into all the world to
proclaim the kingdom of God and to heal
the sick
and then Jesus said in Matthew 18 verily
I say unto you whatsoever ye shall bind
here on Earth I will bind in heaven and
whatsoever ye shall loose on this Earth
shall be loosed in heaven I've had
people that have told me what do I do
about all these soul ties about all
these people that I've been joined to
you go to the Lord you confess it as Sin
and you claim what Jesus did on Calvary
as yours
I said if you confess your sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and cast them as far as the East is to
the West that's right and cleanse you
from all unrighteousness if you come to
him you confess it you recognize it as
Sin then receive that forgiveness don't
beat yourself up over it after that
point believe you have to believe that
he is just and that he does forgive you
and he can't lie that's right amen amen
listen to what he says here in Isaiah he
says it shall come to pass in that day
in that day when you believe on the Lord
Jesus
that his burden speaking of the enemy
his burdens shall be taken away from off
thy shoulders and his yoke from off thy
neck and the Yoke shall be destroyed
because of the anointing when you
surrender to Christ and the anointing of
the holy spirit is then given to you the
Yoke that has bound you to every person
you've ever been joined to it's broken
amen what I have found is is that you go
to the Lord you confess your sin and
then you tell the Lord Lord I am
breaking in the name of the Lord Jesus
Christ and by his shed blood I am
breaking all ties all ungodly ties to
every person the Lord brings to your
your memory and when you do that he says
whatever you bind here on Earth all bind
whatever you lose whatever you sever I
will sever amen
saying O Daughter of Zion shout o Israel
be glad and rejoice with all thy heart o
daughter of Jerusalem for the Lord has
taken away thy judgments he has cast out
thine enemy the king of Israel even the
Lord is in the midst of thee Thou shalt
not see evil anymore for the Lord thy
God in the midst of thee is mighty he
will save amen he will rejoice over you
with joy he will rest in his love and he
will Joy over thee with singing
God is so very good amen amen Mikey I
appreciate you having me on the show
today and I pray that this will be a
blessing to all of our Watchers all the
the audience that are listening and
watching this and please share it uh
there's so many people that are
struggling for years and they don't know
how to get free that's right man thank
you so much for sharing that because it
really gives you the hope that if you
have ever been in this type of bondage
and if we're honest with ourselves we've
all played the Harlot in one way or
another with God we've all gone astray
and the good news is is that he still
wants you he's still pursuing you if we
lay these things down at his feet he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us of all unrighteousness
amen we serve a good God we serve a big
and mighty God to he can give you the
victory over any sin over any addiction
just lay it down before him we thank you
so much for joining us at LED live
please like this video it's an easy
simple way to support this ministry
every time you enter act with a thumbs
up or even leaving a comment that just
says amen it helps get this into the
algorithm so more people can see it we
love you we can't do this without you
guys and we will see you next time on
LED live
foreign
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign